في مدينه غزه مراس الجزيره اسماعيل الغول
اسماعيل ما هي المعلومات المتوفره حول
اشتباكات بين الجيش الاسرائيلي والمقاومه
الفلسطينيه في شمال
القطاع حتى حتى هذه اللحظه تشهد المناطق
الغربيه هدوءا نسبيا وانخفاض ل وتيره قصف
المدفع الاسرائيلي في حين كان يوم امس هو
الاصعب والاشد في الاشتباكات العنيفه
وبالاضافه للقص المدفع المتواصل وقنص قوات
الاحتلال لكن اليوم الملحوظ ان قوات
الاحتلال تتمركز بشكل كبير جدا على
المفترقات والطرقات المؤديه الى منطقه
السرايا والمؤدى منطقه حي النصر هذه
المنطقه التي استشهد فيها منذ صباح اليوم
شهيدين واصيب ثلاث اشخاص اشخاص او حتى ما
يزيد عن ثلاث اشخاص حتى هذه اللحظه في حين
ان قوات الاحتلال تطلق الرصاص بشكل مباشر
على كل من يقترب من هذا من هذه المنطقه في
مقتل اما في الراس او في الرقبه وينجو من
ينجو في تلك المنطقه هناك الكثير من من
العائلات المحاصره وفق المناشدات ما زالت
في تلك المنطقه خاصه في منطقه جنوب حي
الرمال ومنطقه الصناعه هذه العائلات تفتقر
لادن مقاومات الحياه من مياه ومن غذاء
لليوم السادس على التوالي هذه المنطقه دون
اي مقاومات من الحياه حتى بعض الاصابات
التي وصلت او اصابتين وصلاه الى مستشفى
المعمداني كان احداهما ذاهب لاحضار المياه
لطفلته قرب مسجد الكنز فيما اد فيما ادى
ذلك الى اصابه قوات الاحتلال هذا الشاب
ومحاصرته لعده ساعات ونجحت الطواقم ونجحت
الاهالي في اجلاء هذا المصاب لكن على
الحاله الانسانيه نحن نتحدث عن كارثه
حقيقيه وخطوره كبيره في ظل تخوف بلديه غزه
من فيضان بركه الشيخ رضوان الواقعه في
شمال مدينه غزه هذه البركه الكبيره ذات
المساحه العاليه لتجميع مياه الامطار لكن
بعد تدمير قوات الاحتلال مجاري الصرف
الصحي اضطرت بلديه غزه لتجميع ايضا مياه
الصرف الصحي في تلك البركه الان هذه
البركه وصلت الى نسبه حرجه وخطوره كبيره
من الفيضان هذه البركه قد تكون في الساعات
القادمه او في حال منخفض اخر تؤدي الى
فيضان على الاهالي في المناطق الغربيه في
المناطق الشرقيه لهذه البركه من منطقه حي
المناره ومن منطقه حي النفق هذه المناطق
تؤدي اذا فاضت البركه قد تؤدي الى غرق هذه
المناطق بشكل كبير جدا النداء من بلديه
غزه الى كافه المؤسسات الدوليه لتوفير
الوقود والمولدات لتصريف هذه المياه اما
للبحار او لمحطات المعالجه الموجوده في
مختلف مناطق قطاع غزه